Arizona Senator John McCain is calling
for a select committee to investigate
Russian interference in American
politics and allegations of collusion
with the Trump campaign the 2008
Republican presidential candidate joins
us from the Capitol senator good morning
good to see you good morning let me ask
you about what chairman Nunez has done
do you think it was appropriate that he
went to go view these so-called
intelligence reports on white house
grounds well I think there needs to be a
lot of explaining to do I've been around
for quite a while and I've never heard
of any such thing and obviously in a
committee like an Intelligence Committee
you've got to have bipartisanship
otherwise the committee loses
credibility and so there's so much out
there that needs to be explained by the
Chairman and look if this is a very
serious issue it all started with
Russian interference attempt to change
the outcome of our election and so it's
turning into a centipede like these
things have a tendency of doing and
another shoe seems to drop every few
days and I know that's why you have
called for a select committee and
independent committee because of the
seriousness of these allegations should
chairman Nunez reveal his source well
absolutely I can't imagine what why not
and I also believe that the entire
committee should be engaged the reason
why the Armed Services Committee
honestly does is successful as we work
in a bipartisan fashion
senator Burr and Senator Warner on our
Intelligence Committee here in the
Senate work closely together they may
have differences but you've got to have
a bipartisan approach to an issue such
as this if you want to be credit so it
was in if you look at what he has done
so far their demands by Democrats that
he recuse himself does John McCain think
he should recuse himself I would leave
that decision to
the leadership of the House Committee
excused me of the Republicans in the
house probably Paul Ryan but there's no
doubt that
look it's dominating the news it is a
issue of utmost importance and
something's got to change
otherwise the whole effort in the House
of Representatives will lose credibility
I mean that's just obvious you've also
said that you said that President Trump
needs to address this issue what do you
want to hear from him at this point and
have you had any face-to-face meetings
with him would you like to well I think
there's a reception tonight over at the
White House and I'm sure in there but
are you invited I think so what would
you like to hear from the president
senator at this point in time well first
of all I'd like to go back to the the
latest debacle and that is that when the
Democrats rammed through Obamacare they
did it on a strict partisan basis we did
not include the Democrats and
negotiations on Obamacare the issue is
not going away it's imploding in Arizona
Obamacare is imploding we've got to go
back and address this issue on a
bipartisan basis and we can't wait until
people are without health care so and
now we got to move on to tax reform I
would say first thing you should do is
maybe bring that couple of trillion
dollars back to the United States at a
lower tax rate and then
work on infrastructure and you can sit
down together we've got to have some
bipartisanship around here otherwise
we're not going to get much done and
we've got a another government shutdown
looming as you know these are not good
times can I just go back to the Russian
interference in American elections you
have said in some cases this is worth
worse than any single terrorist attack
the dick cheney has said this morning
that in some quarters that would be
considered an act of war what is the
next shoe to drop what do you fear
coming out of this it's hard for me to
predict because I never would have
predicted the Chairman and the House
Intelligence Committee doing what he did
but I think that there is more
information out there there is more ties
to Russia there is more engagement with
with false information there is a lot
more associated with Russian attempts to
affect America our election but there's
also a lot of other Russian activities
going on for example right now they're
attempting to affect the outcome in
France well what about the
demonstrations in Russia right now well
I think it's it's magnificent and it
shows that young people particularly in
Russia are not satisfied with this
corrupt
thug continuing to run their country and
I think it's a great thing but I also
think we're not paying much attention
charlie to the fact that he's murdering
people having people thrown off
balconies having people guy shot who was
in UK Russian who's in Ukraine where's
the yeah to use an old phrase where's
the outrage so what do you want the
president to do in this administration
to do more than simply show outrage or
express outrage like sanctions more
sanctions on Russia obviously they tried
to subvert the fundamental of democracy
and that's a free and fair election
we need more sanctions against Russia we
need to provide lethal defensive weapons
to Ukraine we need to have more military
presence in the Balkans we need to set
up a counter to the very successful
misinformation campaign and propaganda
campaign that they're waging and
particularly in Eastern Europe semadar
can I ask you reported yesterday that
North Korea has carried out another test
of a rocket engine that US officials
believe could be part of a larger
program what needs to be done how urgent
is the North Korean threat I think it's
the most urgent threat that we are
facing right now because if you haven't
this rotund ruler whose behavior is
obviously not rational with a missile
with a nuclear weapon on it that can
reach the United States of America
that's just not a risk that we could
take and we have to prepare for certain
eventualities but frankly the key to
this is China China could shut down
North Korea tomorrow and we should gauge
some of our relationship with China
based on them bringing North Korea under
control but if that doesn't work if the
Chinese will not help now in fact then
they do have deliverable capability from
ICBM to deliver a nuclear missile to the
west coast of the United States would
you wreak
the president take military action to
eliminate that possibility Charlie I
think before I would recommend that I'd
have to know exactly what's going on but
under that scenario that you just
described I don't see how it's
acceptable to have a situation like that
where a real person of not rational
behavior he doesn't think like us to
have that kind of capability and with
his finger on the trigger I'm not saying
we should go to war with them but we
should be accelerating our ability to
counter it all right senator we'll look
forward to talking to you again maybe
after the reception tonight we talk
about partisanship but the Republicans
have some healing to do among themselves
too you all can have a good old
get-together tonight thank you very much
vitam to Arizona goodness thank you very
much for joining us this morning